[Música]
y
ser voluntario
dos palabras muy fáciles de pensar dos
palabras muy fáciles de escribir
dos palabras muy fáciles de pronunciar
sin embargo son dos palabras que cuando
pasan a la práctica se convierte en tal
vez en la fórmula más poderosa que
tenemos los seres humanos para
solucionar nuestros problemas
en una idea brillante y audaz a alguien
de manera voluntaria se le ocurrió
inventar la rueda y desde ese día hasta
hoy el mundo se mueve
voluntariado se define como la acción de
personas o de grupos
de generar acciones
filantrópicas o solidarias
va muy ligado a lo positivo
particularmente considero de que ser
voluntario
te convierte te transforma en un mejor
ciudadano
cuando tenía 16 años en mi natal yacuiba
explotó el pozo gasífero madrejones
x-1001
durante casi tres meses una llama de 200
metros de altura se alzó a unos 46
kilómetros de donde yo vivía
recuerdo inclusive que cuando me echaba
a dormir sentía como que un camión
estuviese encendido fuera de mi casa
las autoridades intentaron minimizar
este evento
en una conexión natural que siempre tuve
con el monte como le decimos allá al
bosque sentía que algo estaba mal en mi
juventud empezaron a despertarse
curiosidades
investigó un poco y pude observar que
los animalitos cerca de la zona
escapaban hacia lugares poblados y eran
cazados comercializados
o simplemente domesticados por los
vivientes del lugar
y se despertó esa chispa y esa necesidad
de hacer algo entendí que tenía que
pasar a la acción y formarme para eso
estudié ingeniería ambiental y soy
bombero forestal desde el año 2006
estuve en variedad de incendios
forestales
pero ninguno con la magnitud que
tuvieron los incendios en la macro
región chiquitana del departamento de
santa cruz bolivia donde se perdieron
más de 5.300.000 hectáreas de bosque
seco chiquitano único en el mundo
un aproximado de 2 millones de animales
también perdieron la vida
de hecho seis colegas míos bomberos
perdieron la vida también en acción
las repercusiones ambientales de este
incidente todavía el día de hoy están
marcando sus impactos las personas que
viven cerca del lugar por toda la
cantidad de carbón la correctiva de las
primeras lluvias los animales en
descomposición sufren hasta el día de
hoy los efectos en su salud a nivel
respiratorio y cutáneo
y nosotros que vivimos acá en la ciudad
también sentimos los impactos de hecho
ustedes sienten más calor hoy que antes
de los incendios
con el equipo de bomberos que me
acompañó hicimos un pacto de honor
hicimos un juramento en el que nos
íbamos a retirar de las áreas afectadas
solamente cuando los incendios se apague
no nos apaguemos
y así estuvimos 40 días
un bombero forestal debería estar
solamente tres días en una línea de
fuego volver a su casa a descansar una
semana y luego retornar si es necesario
aguantamos 40 días pero nada de esto
hubiese sido posible sin la ayuda de un
movimiento voluntario
que empezó a trabajar también en la
ciudad
quiero hacer una mención especial a las
mujeres
las mujeres en un sentimiento de alta
sensibilidad se movieron de manera mucho
más eficiente y rápido que todos los
demás
las mujeres consiguieron alimentos
medicamentos transporte combustibles
entraron a mi lado a la línea de fuego
realmente fueron extraordinarias
para ser más o menos un transporte a lo
que fueron esos incendios imagínense un
día de normal 36 grados de temperatura
te pones un traje de bombero toda tu
protección personal una mochila forestal
que pesa 25 kilos 2 litros de agua para
el consumo algunas latas de atún y tu
herramienta forestal
y cuando tienes entre 30 y 40 kilos de
sobrepeso caminas por un bosque muy
tupido que es nuestro bosque seco
chiquitano hacia una línea de fuego
donde las temperaturas el oxígeno y todo
aquello te complica muchísimo el trabajo
de alguna manera
mucha gente me pregunto cómo es que
resistimos tanto
y yo tengo dos respuestas cuando vos
líquidas o me encendió forestal se
dibuja una línea
que delimita muy bien aquello que se
perdió y aquello que se salvó
muchas veces me paré en medio de esa
línea y observé aquello que se perdió y
cuando ves lo que se perdió ves
oscuridad no se respira bien se ve
muerte y desolación desesperanza
y te sientes mucho más agotado
pero luego ves al otro lado y ves
aquello que se salvó
donde se respira mejor donde se observan
árboles nativos de nuestra región que
serán seguramente semilleros que van a
repoblar aquello que se había perdido se
escucha en el canto de las aves y
entiende que ahí todavía hay vida y que
todo el esfuerzo y sacrificio era
necesario y que teníamos que hacerlo
todos los días porque eso que salvamos
era para nosotros nuestros hijos y los
que vendrán
el otro punto
recuerdo bien que luego los incendios
nos hicieron un reconocimiento algunos
bomberos en el colegio de mis hijos
y más allá de los aplausos y todo eso de
los chicos se acercaron niños y
jovencitos a decirme que querían ser
bomberos forestales comprendí también
que lo que habíamos hecho era un efecto
contagioso
ser voluntario le da un norte a tu vida
si no encontraste ese norte que
normalmente todos buscamos te invito a
que seas parte de esta comunidad mundial
en el área donde física mental y
técnicamente te sientas más cómodo este
evento te dx que es una franquicia
internacional
es realizado por agentes voluntarios que
entienden que tenemos que llevar más
allá de nuestras fronteras una buena
idea
yo creo
que nosotros podemos cambiar nuestra
realidad
estoy convencido de ello el amor es un
sentimiento que dicen que está en
nuestra mente en nuestro corazón no se
puede ver o no se puede tocar
pero cuando le das la mano abrazas a un
voluntario estás estrechando la mano y
abrazando el amor porque es el
desprendimiento más puro que tenemos las
personas para ayudar a los demás
recuerdo que muchas veces las personas
nos decían en las redes sociales héroes
héroes sin capa
particularmente me sentía incómodo
porque lo veía exagerado
busque en internet el significado de
héroe y encontré dos conceptos el héroe
de las tiras cómicas que ustedes conocen
de las películas de las revistas que
están muy de moda además pero también
había un concepto de héroes que habla
sobre personas que hicieron algo
extraordinario en pro de una causa y que
hicieron el máximo sacrificio y recordé
recordé a todos aquellos que nos
ayudaban al frente de las líneas de
fuego recordé a aquellos que perdieron
la vida en un sacrificio extremo que
dormíamos cuatro horas
que perdíamos 6500 calorías por día que
estuvimos inhalando monóxido dióxido de
carbono también todos los días que
nuestra salud se vio afectada que nos
alejamos de nuestras familias que
perdimos algunos trabajos
entonces entendí
que ser voluntario en el área que
decidas te convierte en ese ciudadano
superior en ese mejor ciudadano
y por eso queridos oyentes
con todo lo extraordinario que podemos
ser
entendiendo que el voluntariado nos
convierte en mejor ciudadanos en una
idea brillante y audaz
qué esperan para hacer las próximas
heroínas y para hacer los próximos
héroes
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]